Hey
hey all right guys hey it's actually my
first time going live so let me just try
to figure this out for a while okay
all right guys
hey it's actually my first time I can
feel myself one second right I assume
you can hear me correct
hi everyone once again Oh God so many
things so fiddly okay once I got okay
bear with me it's four more minutes let
me just go live on Facebook as well
okay
right hey everyone
let me see so it's my first time going
live on YouTube and it's a Facebook at
the same time so it's going to be a
really casual chat okay it's actually 9
almost 9 p.m. right now in Malaysia so I
thought maybe it's a great idea for me
to go more life more often at least on a
weekly basis so that I can answer all
your questions in regards whether it's
Fitness related whether it's nutrition
related basically anything that you want
to know more off yeah and hopefully in
the future we'll get to do live workouts
together as well yeah so get your
questions rolling I love all your videos
hi I'm trying to keep up okay so do bear
with me if you have any questions I'm
happy to answer them any questions I
don't whether it's Fitness related or
not Fitness related ok so there's a
question here someone just watched my
300 calories video and you're sweating
did you actually do the workout wait
hang on how do I stop this from moving
so fast ok so I guess one of the common
questions that a lot of we tend to ask
is how do I lose let's say belly fat how
do I lose love handles how do I lose arm
fat basically how do I lose specific
body parts and so I just want to talk a
little bit about that well if you have
been following my videos I've mentioned
a lot of times that you cannot spot
reduce fat what it means is that when
you do total body workout when you do
workouts especially cardio workouts you
are burning fats overall so let's say if
you were to do kickboxing or running you
are burning fat overall so you can't
really spot
reduced-fat you can't just say that you
know what I want to maintain my upper
body and I just want to lose fat on my
lower body it doesn't work that way but
what I want to tell you is that what you
can do is you can tone up on your body
okay so yes by adding strength training
by lifting weights let's say if you were
to do more squats more weight training
you can tone up on your bingo wings you
can tone up around your hips area so as
I've always emphasized it is very
important to combine both strength
training and also cardio not one or the
other okay so whatever I whenever I
structure my workout videos I tend to
structure where the workout combines
both strength and cardio because by
doing it that way it is more effective
for you to have a more effective and
efficient workout in a shorter period of
time
hi guys on Facebook I am just looking
right here because I'm actually going
live on YouTube as well yes so remember
that it's not one or the other it's
always a combination of both so for me
personally I like to do both I like to
do strength training and I also like my
cardio and I like kickboxing so I tend
to do a lot of kickboxing for my cardio
umm can I speak Chinese
well that's a fine question very badly
so what the mincer gel Johanna
motive oil and charm wore through suit
what do white bow issuu Palio if anyone
of you can understand that to reply
right so another question is oh gosh I'm
trying to keep up doing workout at home
or in the gym is more effective um there
isn't an answer whether it's more
effective at home or in the gym because
it really depends on how you do your
workout if you were to do your workout
at home if you were to do total body
workout at home if you have your own
weights if you have your own equipment
and you really push yourself within that
let's say 30 minutes of workout then you
will get the full benefits if you go to
the gym let's
and if you were to just waste time you
know doing a little bit of work out here
and their arrest or talk for the most of
the time it wouldn't be as effective as
well so it really comes down to how you
structure your work out it's not a
matter of location but of course if you
do want to progress if you do want to
mix your workouts up then I would say
going to the gym will has will have its
own benefit as well because then you get
to lift weights you get to join the
classes and it just makes things more
fun and it is a very healthy community
as well high rest Patti from Indonesia I
think you speak so much probably your
life compared to your video
oh haha thank you okay hi Zara from Iraq
um right okay right I see now
when did I get my haircut okay some I
just thought I wanted some casual
questions as well so I actually got my
haircut last weekend on Saturday that's
when I got my haircut I thought you know
why it's about time because I always
have you know this really long hair and
it's quite long and heavy so I thought
I'll give it a good nice cut medium
medium length and but at the same time
it's long enough for me to tie it up
when I go to the gym because otherwise
it's going to be so annoying
how old am I
so I'm actually 27 right now I'm just
revealing it to all of you going on 28
very soon okay ah vivid you lost 4 kilos
in a month well done really really happy
for you keep it up ok 4 kilos a month is
actually a pretty good weight loss ratio
so like I've always say before a good
weight loss ratio and a steady weight
loss ratio is about 2 to 4 kilos a month
so you will be looking between 0.5 to 1
kilos a week and the thing is if the
heavier you are the easier it is for you
to lose weight because your body has a
lot more fat to burn so the lighter you
are the tougher it is for you to lose
weight because your body has less to
burn so for example if I were to do an
intense workout for 30 minutes compared
to someone who is bigger than me who is
heavier than me and the person basically
burns a lot more I might only burn 200
calories in 30 minutes but the other
person may be burning up to 500 calories
so the calorie burned in a workout
session is really different based on
your body composition can I have rice of
course you can have rice and Keita I
actually made a video on why I eat white
rice so be sure to check it out am I
married no I'm not married single no I'm
not married okay what am i coming to
India I know I really want to go to
India hopefully I'll be able to arrange
a workout session there soon because I
don't want I mean I would love to visit
the country but I want to also make it
like a fun work trip where I get to
share my workouts with you guys hi from
iceland hi Astros
um how do you get rid of food cravings
that's a very interesting question and
there isn't one simple answer to it our
body remembers our habits so if you're
someone who is addicted to eating junk
foods or even eating sweet stuff and if
you have been doing it on a regular
basis your body is programmed to create
folders would and to one those food so
you can't just expect to change your
diet overnight you can't just expect
let's say if you were to eat a lot of
sweet you can't just expect to start
eating a really clean solid diet the
next day so what I always encourage
people to do is to slowly eliminate it
not cut it out completely but let's say
if you were to eat - chocolate bus every
day cut it down to one chocolate bar and
slowly cut it down to half and slowly
replace your chocolate cravings to
healthy options such as bliss balls such
as energy balls so you are still getting
the natural sweet from energy balls but
it's a much better sweet compared to
chocolate bars and all that so it is a
gradual step when I first started my
fitness journey I knew very little about
nutrition so I were I was just pretty
much working out did not pay attention
to my food and I was eating pretty bad
as well and my habits did not change
overnight I did not enjoy you know even
vegetables I didn't enjoy vegetables it
took years for me to start to enjoy and
to slowly change my palate and to enjoy
healthy food so don't expect things to
change overnight okay give it months
give it even years depending on how you
how you are and how discipline you are
as well um right
okay so right I'm gonna answer this
question from rushing I know that I've
been doing YouTube videos for the past
four years so I have a lot of YouTube
videos and it can get really confusing
which to follow what I would recommend
you to do is go onto my website Johanna
SOCOM go on to fitness under fitness and
the fitness plan and recipes under meal
plan
and follow the meal plans and lots of
fitness plans because if you were to
follow the meal plans and fitness plans
I've actually structured the workout
according to days so then you won't get
confused as to which your videos to do
so do that okay right okay right is it
wait beauty beautiful beauty hi thank
you for liking my videos hi tanveer like
if I enjoy my videos with your wife
right um okay I'm try to keep up here
guys I'm really trying to keep up here
tell us more about my journey okay um
why not okay why don't I just share this
so let me bring her back to ten years
ago okay I'm gonna take some time to
answer this so when I graduated from
high school I started performance and
media so I actually studied video
production theater so I learned things
on the back end so how to handle the
camera lighting and also how to I guess
present in front of the camera and so I
did that for two years I did my diploma
for two years and eventually I went to
the UK to complete my degree while I was
still doing my diploma in Malaysia in KL
in my final year I actually took up a
personal training cost so I did my
personal training costs under ace so it
was a weekend cost and eventually I got
certified as a personal trainer so then
before going to the UK I practiced
training in Fitness West as a personal
trainer for one whole year then I went
to the UK to further my studies and then
while I was in the UK I continued
training as a part-time trainer so and
then eventually after I graduated I
became a TV producer because that's what
I majored in so that's what I did
full-time a TV producer and because I
was producing and
working full-time I had to give up my
job as a fitness trainer because when
you're a TV producer trust me there is
no way you can juggle two things it just
basically consumed your life so I really
enjoyed what I did but I wasn't
fulfilled because I still enjoy the
fitness element and I wanted to
incorporate that into my life more my
career more so I thought you know what
can I do to incorporate both elements
that's when I started you know I went
online randomly and I and I realized
that maybe it is a good time for me to
go online share what I know about
fitness share my journey and share it
with other people as well and to just
create a community online so then I used
my knowledge in regards to creating
videos and also editing videos combined
that with fitness and started my youtube
channel so that's how I started my
fitness journey and also getting online
um right q she hi yes I am reading this
OH
so and you asked if I start working out
how to start again with full energy well
the thing is like anything in life it is
about building habits and what I like to
tell all of you is be ambitious but
don't be overly ambitious so let's say
if you stop working out for a long time
or even if you have not started working
out ever in your life don't expect to
just start working out every single day
or even five days a week because
realistically it is not realistic for
your schedule and also your body might
not be able to take the intensity that
you want to work towards so it's better
to tell yourself okay I'm starting again
or it is my first time let me try
three times a week to begin with
alternate days so by setting yourself a
realistic goal what you're doing is that
you are setting yourself up for higher
chances of success okay and once you
achieve that three times a week you will
feel very reward you will feel happy
about your achievement and therefore you
would want to continue and stay
discipline so I always believe in being
consistent in whatever you do it's not
just being overly ambitious and because
let's say if you were to set yourself up
to work out every morning you know you
can't do it you know you're not a
morning person somehow chances are you
will fail okay so set a realistic goal
stop three times a week if you're not a
money person then work out in the
evening it's not a problem
there isn't a such thing as the perfect
time to work out you can work out any
time that fits your schedule because the
goal is to be able to stick to it to
stay discipline and I want you to set
yourself up for success any journey any
changes does not happen overnight it
takes time so if you feel one day yes
tell yourself and brush that off and
start again tomorrow that should not be
an excuse for you to say I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna since I've screwed up
once I'm not going to be able to
continue it again it's not that way you
keep trying until you build up a
consistent habit and routine
right hello
that's so true yes okay one second I'm
just gonna both my pads are really cute
yes I know
rusty Nala and also my cats Marty they
are all really cute really lovely can be
a tough nightmare sometimes but yeah
thank you for liking my pets how do you
boost your metabolism you boost your
metabolism by working out more regularly
okay the goal is the more muscles you
have in your body the higher your
metabolism will be so that is why
strength training is important because
you want to tone up and build more
muscles in order to turn your body into
a fat-burning machine at the same time
it is very important to have a healthy
digestion okay people don't realize how
important it is when you have a healthy
and functioning digestion digestive
system that's when whatever good food
you eat your body will be able to absorb
the nutrients okay if you don't have if
you have a sluggish digestive system no
matter how much good food you eat your
body will not be able to absorb the
nutrients so it's just going to waste
so therefore check first of all it's
your digestive guts if you're constantly
feeling bloated lethargic or you're
constantly feeling constipated you have
to start introducing food that will help
with your guts so you can check out my
videos my recent video in fact I just
posted it yesterday for detox drinks
which will help with your guts and also
I think I posted it last year five must
eat food for a flatter tummy and
whenever I post these videos I know that
people might think that is a clickbait
it is not because essentially when you
have a healthy digestion
you will feel bladder you will feel less
bloated therefore you will naturally
have a flatter belly as well okay so
digestive your digestion is
trimly important to boost your
metabolism and also if you work out
regularly it will help to boost your
metabolism there are plenty of
vegetables available in Malaysia yes
black tea is it okay for weight loss
well it will not affect your weight loss
or weight gain but it is high in
caffeine therefore if you are caffeine
sensitive I would recommend to go for
flower teas or even green tea which has
lower caffeine content okay hey hey guys
right it's crazy I'm having Instagram
life right now YouTube and also Facebook
so right let's go onto Facebook right
which green tea brand do I recommend
personally I don't have a specific green
tea brand that I recommend but I do
prefer green tea directly from Japan and
China because somehow they just taste so
much better and they are high quality
therefore you can actually taste the
difference the difference basically it's
actually green when it's infused and
it's not yellow and there's your cheap
green teas somehow it gives a very
yellowy color and it tastes quite bitter
and it has enough to taste higher
quality green tea does not have the
aftertaste it's lighter and it's
refreshing house tour video okay one day
soon soon okay um hi Emily from Malaysia
hi um right okay I want to answer this
question from dong-ho how can you fight
against your fears for example when you
have thoughts that you're not good
enough and then you can embarrass
yourself in front of others I think it's
very natural for everybody to have fears
and self-doubt even for myself I'm not
gonna say that I don't doubt myself ever
even to do this live video trust me I've
put it off so
many times okay I've been wanting to
come on live but I tend to give myself a
lot of excuses blah blah blah and then
so yesterday I was having a chat with a
friend and she's like you just have to
go like if you just have to do it so I
decided yesterday midnight to post a bit
a picture saying that I'm going to go
live because what I've done is I've set
myself up a commitment to do it
therefore I can't not come live right
now so to answer your question how do I
get over my fear I don't think you were
ever fully get over your fear but what
I've taught what I've learned over the
years is never to take yourself too
seriously because once you take yourself
too seriously you tend to overthink
everything that you do not only
overthinking what you think about
yourself but what other people think
about you so even when I first started
doing YouTube videos I didn't want to
upload my first video you know I had to
just shamelessly put my video out there
and I thought to myself it is not
perfect my videos are not great but you
know what put it out there because once
you start doing things that you're
fearful of you will only get better okay
so another thing that I like to always
remind myself is do something that
you're fearful of because that is the
fastest way to grow and even up to today
if I find that I'm at a very comfortable
comfortable stage somehow I would feel
very agitated and I would I would want
to try something new and something
different and just remember don't take
yourself too seriously don't take life
too seriously whatever you do have fun
with it give your best know that you've
given your best and just have fun
through the process it is not the
outcome yes outcome is important but it
is the journey the journey is more
important than the outcome and even when
if you were to relate it back to fitness
it is the same thing if your goal is to
lose 20 kilos 30 kilos yes that is your
goal but you want to make the journey
fun and people who tend to succeed to be
successful and people who tend to enjoy
the journey not just the goal for a lot
of people if they just in towards the
goal they might lose 20 to 30 kilos once
they achieve it
Ben they might just relax and put on all
the weight and even more weight okay so
remember enjoy the journey don't take
yourself too seriously and be shameless
whatever you it is you want to just go
out there ask if you don't know ask
someone if you want something and just
put your intention out there and just
freakin do it like I'm doing it right
now so much you're targeting
um right I'm gonna answer this where is
it now the question just disappeared
I can't wait one second Sarah Sarah Odom
it's white rice bad for you I work in
Asia and I only have access to white
rice and vegetables while while I am at
work should I stay away from it the
answer is no I eat white rice I actually
creates a video on why I eat white rice
it is not about eating white rice or
brown rice it is actually the portion
okay so go on and watch the video it
will hopefully answer all your questions
in regards to eating white rice Hey it
left from Guam okay where am I at I'm
right now in Kuala Lumpur Malaysia okay
right I have been receiving a lot of
comments in regards to weight loss for
older woman so I am going to be working
on that content very soon okay
so yep I'll be working on that all right
Hey will I ever be visiting the state
hopefully very soon I did visit that
five years ago so hopefully again very
soon right
um how much weight should I lived right
with one second
just like trying to catch catch up here
yeah gosh so many countries Kenya gosh I
would love to go that if only I could
just travel everywhere film videos
everywhere kandar workout sessions
everywhere that is the ultimate dream
and my goal moving forward it's to is to
be able to meet all of you guys in
different countries and travel and just
film workout videos and also just you
know conduct a life workout session with
you guys because it is so much fun when
I get to meet you guys and I get to
actually work out with all of you right
let me let me let me say hi from the US
you're early
what time is it there 6:00 a.m. hi I'm
awesome for Pakistan Minnesota okay
whoa your floss cap Carol is it you've
lost 74 pounds from following my videos
guys if you have lost you know if you
have a fitness journey to share with me
don't forget you can always email me
j-serve inspiration at gmail.com sheriff
in this journey and I would love to post
them on my Instagram and also Facebook
because I believe that your fitness
journey will be a huge inspiration to
others as well so yeah do you share it
okay
we'd love to see it high from high Nara
from Saudi Arabia okay right let me just
see
rowing machine 10/10 ver ten-member I
love rowing machine it is rowing machine
I used to do it a lot back then when I
was in the UK in fact I think rowing
machine is a really great upper-body
workout core workout and it also works
on your legs so do do ruin machine if
you can for cardio I love it it's really
great for your back muscles as well so
yeah keep rowing it's great right let's
take some questions from Instagram any
questions guys
let's see aku you have maintained 50
being 50 kilos since you followed my
advice three years ago well done I am
really happy because fitness losing
weight or even gaining weight is one
only a very small part of the journey
maintaining your weight is the biggest
and most challenging part in your
fitness journey so if you're able to
maintain your weight after you have lost
the way what is this is that you have
not only achieved your goal but you've
changed your lifestyle around and that
is what we want when it comes to
changing your habits whether it's in
fitness or just in your life generally
okay so I always believe that Fitness is
not short term it's long term it is not
just a temporary goal it is a lifestyle
change okay so it's a permanent
lifestyle change hence I never recommend
anyone to lose weight or even change
their lifestyle overnight because you
can't sustain that and you can't
maintain that long-term so it's a
gradual process take it easy
be gentle with yourself be kind to
yourself and slowly build and pick up
new positive habits that way you will be
able to maintain it for life right
um okay I'm just probably going to share
with you some of my personal experiences
in regards to because I I'm reading a
lot of comments on love handles thighs
and things like that this is just based
on my personal experience I'm not going
to say that it's going to be it's going
to work for all of you so personally I
find that swimming helps big-time with
my hips and also outer thighs I don't
know why but it really helps a lot with
my outer thighs okay when it comes to
losing um thighs legs fat and all that
because I do have a heavier bottom I
find that doing a lot of jump a stack
sir sizes help with that and when it
comes to toning up on my arms
kickboxing punching and all that really
helps with my arms okay so generally I
like to combine all of it and I really
enjoy all of it so it really depends on
your body it really depends on the
activities that you enjoy but this is
based on my personal experience and just
to share like my current fitness or
workout routine very generally so on I
mean I have a tight line that says never
ever miss a Monday okay so no matter
what time it is no matter how late it is
if you can fit in a short workout on
Monday do it because Monday is the start
of the week so I want you to start
strong okay once you start your Monday
strong somehow you are more likely to
maintain your routine throughout the
whole week so when it comes to my
routine on Monday I tend to like to do
strength training and then on Tuesday it
will be a very quick total body intense
workout which is basically a lot of my
workout videos and on Wednesday it is
back to strength training Thursday it's
back to short and intense workout so I
tend to alternate it Monday Wednesday
Friday strength training Tuesday
Thursday intense training so short and
intense workout and then I would have a
rest on Saturday because I just want to
sleep and do nothing on Saturday and
then on Sunday
when I get a chance to go for my
kickboxing session that is if I have a
good week then I would work out six
times a week typically I would only
manage to fit in four to five times a
week okay based on my schedule that's
how much I can fit in and I I would want
to be realistic with what I can do so
yeah that's pretty much what I do on a
weekly basis sometimes it's long
sometimes it's short right let's see
YouTube can answer your questions on
YouTube now oops okay right
haha
okay guys I'm wait are your fitness
tutorials applicable for men to simply
put yes it is okay my fitness exercises
videos are also suitable for men but
because I know that 80% of all of you
watching right now are female therefore
I tend to also cater more for female but
to answer your question yes my workout
videos are suitable for men they are how
I like to structure my workout is that I
like to structure it really short simple
with very very little equipments because
I want you to be able to start working
out with me at home without basically
without anything and I believe that
Fitness starts from home so you don't
have to pay expensive gym membership you
don't have to go to fancy looking gym
you can start your fitness and you can
start changing from home ok so that's
why the workout videos that I create
tend to be really short really simple
it's something that you can start doing
even if it's 15 minutes guess what guys
if you do it you are moving the whole
point is to get you moving every day
okay that's the goal to get you moving
um hi Ruksana rocks from romania to
answer your question um no eating two
eggs or in the morning isn't wrong it's
fine to eat eggs as long as you don't
you know you don't have high cholesterol
if your cholesterol level is fine it is
fine to eat eggs it's nothing wrong with
that okay I love to have my egg with
toast as well every morning so yep
nothing wrong we try scroll down high
from Egypt love
right guys whoa it's so much fun doing
this cuz you know I really want to
answer all your questions on Facebook
Instagram and even YouTube it's just so
impossible
so I'm in a lot of your questions I tend
to take them on board and try to create
a video out of them because then you
will be able to view them not just one
time but several times as well so I
really appreciate all your feedbacks
because those are inspiration for me to
create my new videos
okay it is crazy to constantly be
thinking of new ideas and new things to
you don't be creating so do keep your
comments coming oops
what I do
ok wait let me see this talk about dance
okay for those of you who do not know
what Don's M stands for is delayed onset
muscle soreness
it's basically feeling extreme pain the
next day after you've done a workout
today okay so I have a video on that I
have a video on how to reduce how to
ease muscle soreness after exercising so
if you can't go into the video and check
it out okay I spoke I basically touch on
how to reduce muscle soreness and also
the reason why you experience pain the
next day or even two days later or even
three days later okay so go and check
the video any plans to get married well
I don't know we'll see what happens
right okay let's see
you can't have a toned body without
going to the gym you can can can have a
toned body without going to the gym you
can get at own body by following my
workout videos as well okay and I'm
actually I actually just filmed a video
yesterday on how to make DIY dumbbells
at home using milk bottles using your
bag putting books in them so you don't
have to buy fancy equipments you can
create really simple dumbbells from the
comfort of your own home using stuff
that you probably already have so I'll
be sharing that very soon as well okay
do I have workouts for beginners for
apps to answer your question yes check
just type in beginner app workouts on my
channel and you will find it for sure
you will find it it's not mean I'm not
going to say it's not difficult but you
will be able to follow the entire
workout
okay right let's see just try to go to
poopoo
mmm so read it really interesting
question here not more question more
like something to share on trees ah I
know I'm going off tangent right now I'm
not talking about Fitness right now but
talking about life purpose and pursuing
dreams one thing I would say is that if
you were to ask me ten years ago
will I be doing this right now will I be
creating YouTube videos will I be
sharing fitness videos the answer is no
if you knew me when I was still a
teenage girl I was one of the laziest I
mean lazy in the sense that I'm not
athletic at all okay I would know I
would not go for a marathon run I would
skip it I would not go for any exercises
no not a chance not a chance I don't ask
any of my friends they know how I was
when I was a teenager so would either
think what I thought that you know ten
years later I will be doing fitness and
also online videos and also YouTube the
answer is no because YouTube did not
even exist 10 years ago so what I would
say about finding your purpose and
pursuing your dreams is that if you
don't know yet what your purpose is in
life if you don't know yet what you want
in life do keep experimenting keep
pursuing and keep trying different
things that makes you happy that you
enjoy and when you enjoy doing something
when you are creating something that you
love and when you're sharing it with the
world people around you will be able to
see that and people around you will be
able to feed off that good energy and
somehow along the way you will be
connected to the right people the
universe has its way to connect you to
the right people the universe has its
way to open up doors and give you
opportunities and somehow link you to
the path that you're meant to be okay do
I know this is my life purpose right now
do I know whether this is something that
I'm going to do for a long time the
simple answer is yes I would love to do
this for a long time I would love to you
know continue share this
this with you guys for a long time well
I've been doing this ten years later my
simple answer is I don't know I am Not
sure because I really do not know what
will be coming up next but what I know
one thing is for sure is if I continue
to grow myself if I continue to learn
every day and if I continue to be
conscious and keep just you know don't
don't be stuck in a bubble keep trying
new things keep looking at ways to grow
then I would I would want to I I know
that I'm doing the right thing I would
know that I'll be happy and if I'm
honest to my gut instinct that's all
that matters in life I feel it is really
important to listen to your gut instinct
that is one thing that I've learned and
that is one thing that I've been doing
throughout my entire life which is to
listen to your gut instinct because your
gut will never fail you every decision
every important decisions that I've made
in my life when it feels right you know
it's right okay if it's if something is
bothering you then you know that it
might not either be the right timing or
if it's not meant for you then just let
it go okay don't force yourself to do
something if it doesn't feel right
I hope I'm making sense there do I
believe in the law of attraction yes
absolutely everything that you want you
can't just you have to put your
intention out there you can't just say
oh I wish I have this oh I wish I have
that you you have to create intention
out there first of all and you have to
take action okay
putting an intention is only one thing
but taking action and working towards
that is another thing and when you start
working towards something that you
really want in life even when it comes
to losing weight then you are attracting
all the right things or the right people
all the right energy to create the right
environment for you to get what you want
and I also just want to take this
opportunity to share with all of you a
little bit about the new platform that I
started called her Network I know that
it is very confusing to a lot of people
what is her network why are you seeing
then people on my youtube channel right
now what are all these ladies doing on
my youtube channel and so I just want to
you know just take the time to share a
little bit about her Network so a year
ago I had this vision of creating and a
basically a female platform that would
support and encourage women to grow and
be the best version of yourself
basically and I know that I can't do it
on my own doing things on your own is
you can only grow that far but when you
start collaborating with different
people people that shares the same
vision and shares that the same ideas
ideas with you you're able to reach
further you're able to expand further
you're able to learn quicker and you're
able to basically reach out to more
people so and I believe that wellness is
not just about fitness it's not just
about eating well it is also about your
mind it combines everything it combines
fitness it combines nutrition and it is
also about your mind and your thoughts
so to me that is a complete wellness
package okay that is being hold to
yourself so I wanted to share different
elements with all of you besides fitness
and also wellness hence I started
contacting you know I started getting in
touch with all these different ladies
that I knew share the same vision as me
and for instance you know I don't
I personally don't practice yoga and I'm
not a yoga instructor and I know that a
lot of you want that on my channel so I
thought how can I share yoga um
workout with you with all of you if I
don't do yoga so then the best way is to
collaborate with niihka with the yoga
teacher and share that so her network
basically brings all these different
creators together all these different
ladies because I want to offer you a
quite a variety of content content that
would support you not just in fitness
not just in nutrition but also to give
you a better understanding of life in
general whether it's also whether it's
also related to fashion you know makeup
because sometimes when we look it on the
outside it makes us feel good on the
inside so yes I will still be
contributing content every week okay my
videos are up on every Wednesday and you
will see different videos for different
creators on Monday and also Friday so
I'm not disappearing from the channel
not way no way integrity no chance but
you will get to also see different
creators sharing different content on
Monday and Friday okay and hopefully I
will be coming live every Thursday as
well so I really hope you all will start
to embrace the change right now that I'm
doing with my channel I hope that you'll
be will be supportive towards the
network and I really want this to you
know grow and be a very supportive
community where we can share and just
talk to each other on every topics every
single topic um while I make a separate
account for her network to simply answer
your question is no the reason why I
chose not to do that I did think about
it to begin with but I decided not to do
that is I understand that it's very
confusing right now to a lot of people
it is very confusing that you do not
know where my content is coming up and
it's just confusing with all these
different ladies but I wanted to be able
to offer these contents to my existing
followers okay so if I were to create a
separate channel that means that I'm
reaching pretty much nobody to begin
with and it means that I'm building up a
whole new audience and that would take
time so I wanted to be able to share
this with all my existing followers
which are pretty much you guys instantly
and I want all of you to gain and learn
from all these different videos as well
so to simply answer your question no the
plan is not to start a new channel for
her network but her network has its own
separate Facebook page Instagram page
and also website and I hope you'll find
it useful because there is so much more
exciting content on it such as teaching
parents how to cook healthy with their
kids yoga inspirational talks beauty
fashion which I obviously don't do I am
absolutely bad when it comes to makeup
as you can tell from my videos
gosh I'm so bad at makeup you have no
idea
and yeah just thinks that I don't I'm
not an expert in I want to be able to
share that with you okay um again
another question how am i I'm 27 going
on 28 yeah that's all oh I am right now
cool well I have I have a group class
workout yes I do
occasionally do group classes and
hopefully I am planning to do that I
mean I'm based in Kuala Lumpur Malaysia
so hopefully I will be able to do that
once a month and just get all of you who
are here to come on board right I just
wait
okay um Just Answer answer and my cables
question on Instagram what is the
difference between intense strain
training and strength training
um what intense training can also be
part of strength training it really
depends on how you structure your
workout but when I mentioned it by
intense training what I was referring
more to is the high intensity cardio
body weight type workout so strength
training
if generally strength training will not
increase your heart rate - you know like
a maximum point unless if you were to
lift light weights and do it without any
rest then yes you know your heart rate
will also elevate by generally strength
training if you were to lift heavier and
do less repetitions and rest between
sets it will not constantly keep your
heart rate elevated so you have a moment
where your heart rate is elevated and
then it goes back down to resting and it
goes back up again with intense training
most of the time through almost
throughout the entire workout your heart
rate is constantly elevated okay that's
when your body is constantly burning
calories and your body is constantly
burning and yeah simply put that is
intense training but yes you can also
have intense training as part of
strength training if you were to do
strength training with very very very
little bricks in between okay
are we having a yoga video from niihka
any time soon yes Nico's video is up on
not on every Monday on alternate Mondays
so yes you will be getting yoga videos
soon
and really cha do I like it boxing yes I
love kickboxing and hi from India I mean
not for me - hi Joanna please reach out
I am OH
guys if I don't get to answer all your
questions I am truly sorry I'm trying my
best and my phone or Instagram is
actually 1% laugh so it's probably gonna
die very soon okay
hi for the Philippines greetings from
Norway gosh
I'm planning to go Norway end of this
year hopefully okay right one second let
me just unplug that charging my phone
oops very tango oh well
no okay Oh God
so many things right just gonna do it
this way okay that's probably the
easiest way right now oh sorry
okay next awkward life moment hey from
cardiff UK III lived there for 3 years
loved Cardiff loved the Welsh cakes gosh
missed them hi Len Lavanya from the UK
Cardiff I have to go back and visit soon
any tips for losing belly fat I have a
lot of videos on that please do take the
time to watch it
I created probably a lot of videos on
that so just type benefit or tummy fat
in my channel and you will be able to
find all of it and a lot of my videos
are very informative and I sort of I
know to some people it might be boring
but I wanted to do it that way because I
believe that if I provide knowledge and
information to all of you then you will
be able to continue on your fitness
journey independent
independently basically and that is my
goal eventually is for you guys to be
able to continue on your fitness journey
knowing exactly what you're doing
while you're doing it and if you do fall
off track you know how to pick yourself
back up okay so hence my a lot of my
videos are very informational because I
one I just want it to be that way to
provide information for all of you I'm
trying to put I'm trying to make my
phone Stan it's not going to stand okay
you know what let's just take this out
right
um just going to answer this question
can you ask what is the best time to
exercise like I've said there isn't a
best time to exercise it really depends
on your schedule it really depends on
what works best for you so if you can
only feel your workout at night by all
means do your workout at night because
then you will be able to stick to your
routine personally for me I like to work
out I mean I usually like to work out in
the morning but right now somehow my
schedule works better if I were to work
out in the evening I can't do my work
out too late at night as well because if
I do it too late and I I can't I
struggle to sleep that's when you start
seeing random instant story post because
I can't sleep okay so that's just me if
you do struggle to sleep at night then
once you have done your workout then
avoid late night workouts okay please
advice weight loss for new mummies do
watch the yoga video which I just did
with Nika that would pretty much get you
started as a new mom and I'm hoping to
do a lot more workout videos with Nika
on how to lose weight as a new mom and
being a mom as well I'm not a mom so I
would want Nick had to share that more
because she has gone through it and she
looks so good hi from the US
[Music]
amenda reading any good books right now
good books right now um I like John C
Maxwell I just find his book really real
motivating inspirational and also yeah I
mean if I don't get the chance to read
what I tend to do is I tend to listen to
audiobooks in the morning when I am
getting ready so I do listen to
audiobooks check that out right um for
those of you who are fasting right now I
just want to say you know happy Ramadan
I'm happy to know that my Ramadan meal
plan and also workout plan are actually
helping all of you and yeah it took us
quite some time to create that so I'm
really happy that if you're following
the meal plan and workout plan do keep
it up it's only one and a half weeks
away from the new year right now
so have fun okay have fun hey sach Cunha
from Glasgow Scotland hi can we do our
workout during periods yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes you can do your workout
during periods it shouldn't be stopping
you um again I have a video on that I
have a video on period and exercising so
do search on that as well okay so when
you're on your period if you feel really
uncomfortable if you if you're in pain
for the first day that I would say no
take a rest listen to your body rest for
the first day and if you do feel better
on the second day then do some really
gentle exercises such as yoga if however
you are completely fine you don't
experience any pain any cramps and
bloating then you don't wat by all means
you can continue with your usual workout
routine okay in fact here's a fun fact
as well usually on your first or second
day of period we women can handle more
pain okay so let's say if you're feeling
fine and you do your normal workout try
to push yourself at that
further you will somehow be surprised
that you can lift further
I mean lift more push yourself further
and you know just really go all out
somehow our body is more resistant to
pain during our periods so give that a
try I'm not kidding do give it a try
and ronita I love Indian food in fact I
just had it two days ago over a lunch
meeting love Indian food I love all
kinds of food right let's see okay let's
go into Facebook good evening
hello Michel from Wales
right sorry hive in skills from
Philippines oh gosh don't simply click
your Ella be careful with the buttons
and fear memories thank you for
everything you've done
if helped us in so many ways and I'm so
glad I started watching and following
your videos thank you so much guys for
continuously you know constantly
watching my videos and continuously
supporting what I do because this would
not even exist
without all of you so thank you thank
you for being my inspiration really and
I really mean it when I say that so yeah
I mean I do for your comments I do read
them I can't answer all of them
unfortunately because it's just not
possible all the time but I do read them
and I it makes me you know it makes me
happy somehow it inspires me to create
new videos and inspires me to continue
to do what I do especially on my down
days ok I am NOT always positive I'm not
always like yeah I'm gonna do this I am
so energetic I am NOT always like that I
have my down days as well I do question
myself as well sometimes I do dump
myself and ask myself why am i doing
what I'm doing you know who's watching
and things like that
so I do have my down days as well and
whenever I read your comments it helps
to lift me up in a way it helps to it
gets me back on track with what I do and
it keeps a it makes me not question
myself as much and you know not trying
to not to have negative thoughts
constantly so yeah thanks for that
nousheen hi from India hi
how did she help you what is this I'm
waiting for your new videos I just
uploaded yesterday the detox tea videos
so yeah I'll be uploading I'll be
sharing new videos every Friday
no sorry every Wednesday hi Rommel
congratulations on passing your ACE
certification Congrats I'm so happy I
hope that you will continue on the
journey of helping people and changing
lives okay I really hope that and it is
a really rewarding journey so you're on
the right path either this is a really
interesting question from mark valina do
I count calories the simple answer is
right now no no I don't count calories
but I guess the question is should you
be counting calories because back then I
would say maybe three or four years ago
calorie counting is sort of like a big
thing and a lot of people tend to count
calories when it comes to losing weight
it is promoted to count calories if you
want to lose weight and things like that
by now adays because of all the
different diets and methods if you were
to go vegetarian or vegan people don't
really count the calories and all that
what what is my take on all come
basically what is my take on counting
calories well for me I think that if
you're new in your journey if you're new
to fitness if you're new to nutrition I
personally think that it is important
for you to understand the fundamental
and the basic of calories where your
calories come from how does it work what
does it do to your body and things like
that because a lot of people do not know
how much calories is in a food for
instance you always get things like oh I
don't eat you know I eat very little but
that person might be drinking like
really high sugar drink or even
Starbucks you know like a Starbucks
coffee they don't realize that those
drinks are filled with calories so if
you're new to fitness if you're new to
nutrition I would say it is very
important for you to first understand
calories understanding um how much
calories is enough food and all that
once you go on to your fitness journey
once you understand all the basic and
all the fundamentals once you're eating
healthy then no you don't have to count
your calories every single day because
that is a nightmare and that can be an
obsession as small entity and it's not a
good obsession if you're constantly
worrying about how many calories you eat
every day oh my god who trusts me even
when you eat healthy food that should
make you feel good you don't feel good
because you're just worried about the
calories that goes into your body so yes
understand calories if you're new in the
fitness journey but once you understand
fundamental once you start eating
healthy then no don't be obsessed over
counting calories okay just as long as
for me I practiced the 80/20 concept eat
healthy 80% of the time and allow
yourself to indulge in moderation 20% of
the time okay because the goal is I
believe in moderation
everything you do moderation if you're
enjoying like like maybe a piece of
cheesecake you can have the cheesecake
by share it with a friend there is
nothing wrong with indulging in
moderation it's all about balance if you
you know stop yourself from indulging
eventually you will also indulge but it
will only become worse because then
instead of having one small tiny piece
of cheesecake you might just ended up
eating you know like a whole huge slice
of cheesecake so I personally practice
the 80/20 method or concept or idea
everything in moderation oh whoa I'm
already live for more than an hour right
let me take a few more questions video
is not loading really personal loading
it's loading it slowly my video is
loading
it's her net we're going to make a
meet-and-greet section sorry madam
everything it's whole network oops
gosh sorry my phone just fell off is her
Network gonna make a meet and greet
session
yes yes yes yes yes yes the answer is
yes and we're planning something so
hopefully you'll be soon
okay yes right let me go to Facebook
Oh
okay so um what was it where was I
sorry just got distracted loss
you
guys I I just read a question I can't
track it back but the question is on
what are my thoughts on zero plus zero
percent fat free food I again I have a
video on that talking about food labels
and how confusing it can be whenever a
food or product is labeled as zero
percent chances are they are yes they
may be very low in fat but chances are
they might contain a lot of sugar okay
so don't be fooled by the food labels go
and watch my video and learn how to read
and understand food labels okay it's
really important to flip and read the
back part of the ingredients list and
also nutrition lists and really
understand what is in the product not
just the front part
Oh sugar free or fat free Oh gluten free
and all that kind of I like to call
rubbish okay flip read the back part of
the food and ingredients list okay II
okay guys so I hope you enjoy you know I
hope you have enjoyed this live session
let me know if you want to have more
live session I'm hoping to do it every
Thursday at this time so it's going to
be nightly in my time and it's going to
be really early in the morning in
America midnight Australian time about
evening time for those of you in India
and also in Asia let me know if you
enjoy this live video do leave your
comments and yeah hopefully I'll be able
to do more live session and also reply
to all of you yes I'm just reading your
comments again who don't live right
let's see this pay for what pay for life
videos no you don't have to pay for live
videos when it's my birthday
let me just announce it it's the 22nd of
September okay
22nd of September - to 22nd okay
I'm sorry from all your workouts well
it's good pain okay
if you feel soreness the next day it is
good pain you feel soreness because in a
way your muscle is breaking down and
growing so pain from workouts are good
okay greetings from Croatia
hello Wow okay all right oh oh you or do
you prefer like a live session every
weekend I don't know which one is better
Saturday Friday I mean nobody's gonna
watch a Friday video you know
everybody's going to go out have their
late-night parties and things like that
so yeah I thought Thursday is a good
time before Friday comes I don't know
what do you think I'm trying to keep up
with your comments hi Sharma on Facebook
Thursday's good Thursday yes
who votes for Thursday Thursday life
session OMI Malaysia yes I am in
Malaysia right now
hi oh it's going everywhere right that's
on purpose okay
so I'm going to go offline right now I
hope that you enjoyed this live chat and
yeah see you next Thursday same time and
yeah let me know which works better than
Thursday or weekends I'm still open to
ideas and yeah just let me know in the
comments below okay and do check out my
latest video which I uploaded yesterday
on detox with drinks do you want to see
my water right now what I have right now
this is what I've been drinking every
single day for the past seven days now
before that I have to admit that my
water intake has been absolute rubbish
so I made the commitment to drink a lot
more water and therefore I thought
you'll be a great idea to share the
videos with you so this is just pretty
much lemon and cucumber infused water
okay and what I do is I'll tend to bring
two of these to work everyday this is
just tea I used elevate efore this one
can you see it Ella verity you can use
green tea you can use flour teas any tea
that you like and what I've done is I've
added chi acids in it okay I know you
can't really see it but you have
attached a seat into it and it's just
one tablespoon of chia seeds - about two
cups of water
I'll be sharing this recipe as well okay
and that those chia seeds really really
really feels BR chassis are so filling
it will help you to reduce cravings and
just reduce hunger overall as well okay
so yep one infused water another chia
seeds water try it out I love it I love
it check out my video yesterday I
unloaded
for recipes on the infused water okay so
good
hi shreya
okay make the commitment to drink more
water for the next and least you know
ten days and obviously drink more water
every day okay let's make that
commitment to drink more water
cheers guys I'm gonna go offline right
now and try to have an early night as
well it's 10 p.m. right now I try to go
to bed before midnight every day so yeah
trying to trying to fingers cross bye mm
see you live soon and now how did I do
this on YouTube bye